all right so we have Steve from
um MSC molecular medicine and his
interest is and bacterial genomics
immunoinformatics and Drug Discovery all
right that's pretty interesting can you
also let us know from which university
you're from
and what about the rest of you who have
joined us can you also introduce
yourself in the chat box
yes hello Rachel it's good to have you
back
uh so Russell uh is a research assistant
in genome Center at Joshua and his
research interest is in metagenomics
thank you so much
I'm curious to know
um
can you also let us know what is your
motivation to join in the field of
research is it as a part of your degree
or do you plan to
um
go for PhD or
all right Steve is from Jomo Kenyatta
University of Science and Technology and
is currently working as a client for
medication
all right perfect thank you so much
and how would you
um rate your skills in bioinformatics
this is a general question for all the
participants uh are you a beginner or
intermediate or Advanced expert
foreign
all right so Russell said he has
intermediate knowledge thank you so much
and Stephen said a few sets there's a
junior brand magician and intermediate
skill all right so we do have a couple
of in paramedic experts amongst us and
what about the rest of you
I'm curious to know about you guys as
well
tanmo is also intermediate
then why can you also introduce yourself
in the chat box like the rest of them
you can let us know about your
educational background and research
interests
[Music]
all right I can see the few more
participants have joined and um for
those of you who have just joined us I
will be starting with the webinar in
just two to three minutes and meanwhile
we are waiting it would be great if the
participants can introduce themselves
here the participants have already
started introducing and uh letting us
know about their research interests all
right so we have a response in chat from
tan Moy he is a current fourth year
student of microbiology and is
interested in DNA specific virus
thank you so much
and what about the rest of you
I think almost everyone has covered
all right thank you so much for your
patience we will be just starting in
just a few more minutes thank you
all right so without further Ado let's
start with today's webinar hello
everyone a very warm greeting to one and
all my name is
and I would like to welcome you all for
the webinar on omixlogic bioinformatics
and data science research Fellowship the
research fellowship program has been
designed to help young researchers and
students take advantage of the
bioinismatic resources for the analysis
of complex life science data and become
well worked in bioinformatics research
fellows participate in cutting-edge
bioinformatics research led by expert
mentors and the fellowship program will
offer a combination of online resources
and mental guidance to prepare you and
help you complete a bioinformatic
project
so before we begin with today's webinar
for those of you who are joining us for
the very first time let me also take a
brief moment to introduce you to the
team behind the program we are a
us-based bioinformatics company who is
working with multiple academic and
Commercial collaborators to develop easy
to use analytical tools and our mission
is to make bioinformatics more
accessible
and as part of our mission our team is
working with local and Regional
coordinators that are helping refine
local program Logistics and adapting
them to the needs of students and
researchers around the world and this
training has been completed by over 24
000 participants from 187 countries in
over 300 workshops in six different
specialization tracks that includes
oncology infectious diseases Precision
medicine neuroscience and data science
for biomedical data
and as a part of the training you will
also have access to the omic storage
resources which takes the combination of
training modules data analysis tools
curated project data sets and
interactive sessions with mentors to
give the student a clear part of the
Bloom's taxonomy pyramid
and this also comes with an access to
the omixology courses which includes
courses on bioinformatics Precision
medicine multiomics including genomics
transcriptomics metagenomics and
epigenomics data science that includes
bioinformatics using RN python as well
as chemen for map and example projects
of different fields which you could
learn from and replicate for your
research work the omex logic platform
also give options for analyzing a given
data
and these data sets and Associated
Publications can be used in several ways
for instance you can learn
bioinformatics without any coding at all
and for those interested in opting the
non-code pathway they will be given
directions to access the T by info
platform for bioinformatic processing
and Analysis of data and the platform
includes demo pipelines as well as data
management and Analysis Scout
infrastructure to run the bioinformatic
Pipelines and different stages of
analysis are performed in different
sections on the small diamics platform
and for those interested in learning to
analyze data through coding we provide
the omics logic code playground which
will help you develop coding skills
while learning popular packages in our
programming and python to visualize
annotate and analyze complex patterns in
biological data
so now to view the various courses
example projects and student projects
you need to first sign up on the omics
logic learn portal before that let me
walk you through a brief demo on what a
completed profile on the portal list
so once you sign up on the portal these
are the features that you need to update
on your account that is a completed
profile will have a profile image put a
name with appropriate capitalization
link to your social media handles a
brief bio about yourself that will
consist of your education background and
research interests the mentors can view
your progress under the activity tab the
courses you are currently completing
will appear under the core system
finally after the completion of your
coursework the certificates will appear
under the certificate step so that was
all about how you can update your
profile so with that let us Begin by
signing up on the ominous clone portal
with that to let me paste the link for
signing up in the chat box for those of
you who have not signed up on the portal
yet please visit the link and um I'll
walk you through how you can sign up
all right uh Russell has shared a very
I'm sure um one of our team members will
look into your uh
issue and get that
all right so that was the link for
signing up so for those of you who are
signing up for the very first time head
on over to the link and click on the
create an account option
so once you click here you can sign up
either by entering your name providing
email ID and a password or you can also
sign up using any of your social media
handles that could be your Google
account Facebook account Apple account
GitHub account or even Twitter
so that is how you can sign up and for
those of you who already have an
existing account on the portal you can
simply click on the login now option
that you see here and then enter your
existing email ID and password and
directly sign
so I'm monitoring the chat box for your
responses once you have signed up please
put it in the chat box as a yes so that
I know I can proceed ahead
I'll pause for a couple of seconds and
after that I'll um head on over to show
you how you can navigate through the
portal
[Music]
thank you so much for confirming
and if you're facing any technical
issues you can also let us know and our
team is here and we'll be happy to look
into it all right thank you so much
all right without further delay I'm just
going to sign in but along the way if
you uh need me to repeat any steps you
can let me know and I'll be happy to
show you
and since I already have an account on
the portal I'm going to click on sign in
and once you sign in we'll be able to
see the courses page and when you scroll
down below you will see a search bar
that says looking for a specific course
so here if you enter a keyword that is
of your research interest that will show
you the various courses and example
projects that make use of that concept
so for instance if you are interested in
learning to uh analyze transfer products
data sets and you want to get started
you can enter the keyword transcript
forming and that will show you several
courses on bulkarn AP single cell rnac
and even analyzing transforming data
sets using RN Python Programming and
several other example projects that
makes use of transfer promo data and now
coming to the part about setting up your
project you can click on the blue bar
that is welcome back with your email ID
when you click here it'll directly take
you to your account settings so here you
will see a button that says profile when
you click on this that will enable you
to edit all the features that I was
talking about in my presentation before
so just as reminder make sure that your
name is in proper capitalization you add
a profile image for yourself add a bio
consisting of your education background
and research interests as well as update
your social media Handles in my case
I've linked my LinkedIn account and my
work ID
and then you will also see several other
tabs in your account settings that
consist of activity tab there and
Community manager and the program Mentor
will be tracking learning progress you
can take the course progress review
under the courses tab under the projects
tab it will display the research project
once you publish and then another
interesting area that I want to show you
is the project step when you can take a
look at all of the student projects that
have been carried out on a diverse range
of fields from infectious disease to
Neuroscience to machine learning to
oncology and so I'll paste the link in
the chat box for the participants one so
that you can navigate through and take a
look at it so that was all about
navigating through Lumix logical and
portal so now to learn more about the
research fellowship program and the
various specialization tracks I'd like
to pass on the stage to one of my
colleagues sonalica or do something
thank you SRI gauri
options
all right so before I really start
discussing with you all about the
different resource specialization tracks
that a research fellow can work on with
us I really wanted to know about the
backgrounds from which uh you all are by
background I mean IU from biotechnology
field a bioinformatics vein and some of
you might have already figured out with
specific field they want to carry out
their research on some of you might also
be uh learning about these different
queens and then would figure out which
field they want to pick that's perfectly
fine too let us first of all see how
many of you are from biotech field or
bioinformatics or microbio biochemistry
can you please write down your research
backgrounds or educational backgrounds
in the chat box please
so that I know we have our audience from
virtual fields
let's keep this session more interactive
so we have kept this session for you all
today so that we can learn about your
interests and we can uh answer any
questions if you have in the direction
related to your interests and uh the fee
that you want to update nurani is saying
microbiology sharp Oneness for from
Pharmacy field okay
is from biochemistry and molecular
biology
Calvin Darius
janitol we have open and akanksha also
with us and we have beans madhvi has
also joined High March wheel
hi Rob partha pratiksha
professor anovar rasi
foreign
and chemistry field as well that is
interesting have you uh thought of the
research field that you really want to
work on
so from for people from Pharmacy I can
assume they are interested in chem
informatics or structural biology or if
it's another field you can tell me that
as well just want to understand what
specific research track we want to work
on
so when we maybe you can answer my
question in a while the specialization
track
so when we talk about
uh omics data analysis we basically
refer to different types of honest data
techniques like we have transcriptomics
with us or genomics or metagenomics or
epigenomics or proteomics right so
bioinformatics basically deals with
these different omics data analysis
now when you want to work with these
different homage data analysis there
could be different research uh
specialization tracks or Fields where
you can apply the knowledge that you
gain from these different data analysis
techniques the basis obviously Remains
the Same where for genomics you're
interested to look at specific variants
mutations or understand phylogenetic
Trends or evolutionary Trends look for
pathogenesis and then for
transcriptomics you are more interested
to look at specific types of genes
annotate their Pathways there may be
repurpose drugs uh why which could
effectively reverse the or reverse the
differential gene expression of specific
set of genes metal genomics you would
like to look into the abundance levels
and classified taxonomy for different
microbial communities epigenomics you
want to understand the environmental
factors response responsible for a
specific type of condition in hand
so the different types of data analysis
we understand but what are the different
types of research tracks where these
different analysis types could be
explored
one is infectious diseases like Ebola
malaria sargof2 and I am right now on a
research project uh topic page actually
here is the link you can take your time
and go through it I'll just discuss this
program page with all of you and then
I'll I'll I would love to know what are
the fields that you want to work in so
that we can really discuss how we can
proceed one step ahead and start with
the research uh proposal
okay so the first thing that I mentioned
is infectious diseases now on this
project topics page what we have tried
to do is we have tried to put together
these different research specialization
tracks and then the types of data
analysis that is possible for you to
work on and we have just listed some
questions that you can
um answer maybe for these different
types of data analysis techniques
obviously there are a lot of
possibilities we have various several
questions as well and if you are a
student a B Tech BSC mtech MSC student
or a PhD scholar or a researcher from a
wet lab domain or field and you want to
get your hands dirty with bioinformatics
analysis and you're wondering what type
of research topic would you like to work
on you can explore this page and come up
with a research and trust that you want
to really work on and then we can get
started that is the main objective to
have this page put together now a lot of
students come to us uh for working on
the dissertation projects and they have
one type of question so we have two
types of groups one group they know what
type of question they want to work on
because they have a specific type of
research interest already defined
another type of growth they have an
interest but they are not very sure uh
how can they start working on the
research question or there are also
students who are from wet lab Fields
like biotech microbio biochemistry and
medical sciences and they want to learn
about bioinformatics and then they want
to understand the scope and the fields
and then uh start working on a specific
type of research question all right so
for these different types of people we
would first of all take you through an
in-depth knowledge or an understanding
of these different data analysis we'll
then pick a specific type of data
analysis and give you a specialized
training on it and then pick a research
field that you want to work on applying
the data analysis technique skill set
that you gain from your training now the
different resource specialization tracks
that are available for you to work on
one is infectious diseases
on this project topics page we have put
together the example projects as well
then you can go through
now what are these example projects if
you go to the amishologic learn portal
and click on the courses tab
uh you have several courses here that is
one thing that you can go through and
upscale your skill set and apart from
this we also have some case studies or
projects these case studies or projects
will help you understand how to answer a
research question a specific type of
research question using a specific type
of skill set
so if it's transcriptomics you want to
see what type of projects do we have
here with transcriptomic data analysis
so you will get the list of these
projects up here you can open up any one
of them and these are short case studies
for you to get a good taste of how
research questions would be at rest for
beginners who are new to this field and
would like to learn they can go through
these case studies now on the project
topics page what we have done is we have
put together these different example
projects or case studies I will say that
we have available on the uh portal they
are hyperlinked with the links of their
specific case studies you can click on
them and go through them to have an
understanding
the second type of research
specialization track that we are working
on extensive needs oncology and uh for
the field oncology there are different
data analysis types that you can work
with be a transcriptomic genomic
metagenomic epigenomics structural
biology chemical informatics also there
is a possibility to do a multi-ohomics
integration and metagenomic data
analysis under the field of oncology
now there are several different research
question types that one can answer and
all of them are listed out here you can
date your time in each store this
project topics page uh at your own pace
some example projects related to the
field which are on cancel macrophages
pdas tumor microenvironment and we have
our tcga study where the data was taken
from tcga to understand or predict the
liver cancer risk
the next thing that we have is precision
medicine and for precision medicine
again different types of data analysis
techniques that are possible be it
transcriptomics clinical data analysis
epigenomic and genomic
and an example project related to
Precision medicine and then you have the
field agriculture very interesting field
that is also gaining a lot of interest
by bio uh implementation and also a lot
of agriculturalists are interested to
now learn how bioinformatics could be
used for uh working with the data the
data from plants and crops and also
understand the association between
microbiome and the plants so the
analysis possible becomes genomic
transcriptomics and Metal genomics
so that was about the field Agriculture
and then you have neurosciences where
you can apply transcriptomic studies uh
all the genomic studies and
microbiometer genomic studies are
possible as well in depth that you can
work upon for Alzheimer's and then you
have metabolic disorders where again the
transcriptomic studies could be explored
and space omics where you have the phase
transcript atomics epigenomics and
metagenomic data analysis that could be
done
now now tell me in the chat box everyone
what are your areas of interest if you
have figured out even if you have not
you can let us know in the chat so that
we can discuss with you a one-on-one
about your interests and get you started
so uh let us begin with akanksha
akanksha what is your research interest
you can put in the chat
as well
Clement Darius
we would like to know what are your
areas of research and trust you can put
them in the chat
I'm waiting for responses hidayah is
seeing Neuroscience epigenomics perfect
Rob
thank you Vijaya and Dennis for your
replying in the chat infectious diseases
but you want to go through perfect
Clement yes I remember and
akanksha is interested in multiomics
data analysis and ingest molecular
aspects
okay
now some of you might also be entrusted
to learn about the different
possibilities of research questions that
could be addressed using this these
different types of data analysis for the
piece that I just mentioned about but
that you can also explore some of the
existing research projects by our
research fellows they have completed
these projects and they've uploaded them
on the omnisogic learn portal you can
click on this projects tab right here
and you'll be then redirected to these
different projects by our research
fellows so you'll get to know how they
went through a specific type of data
analysis technique and then picked up a
research question and addressed the same
so you can pick up the specific type of
feel that you are interested to explore
transatronic data studies for oncology
and you'll get these projects listed out
you can open them and just like a
publication they have all the different
sections of their uh project added here
the data set that they explored abstract
introduction is given methodology
it is all this discussion and conclusion
also one of the questions that we hear
the most is what about the data uh what
specific type of data can they work with
so there are two types of individuals
I've seen one cohort or one group is
such where they are generating data in
their own lab and they're interested to
uh analyze it and the other cohort could
be the one who are interested to learn a
skill set and apply it in a specific
type of research field but they don't
really have the data so for them you
need not worry there are various public
repositories from where you can explore
data and extract some specific sets that
you would like to work on specific
samples and then prepare data process it
and then start analyzing it so we like
we leverage a lot of public repositories
uh we take the data from there based on
the type of a research question interest
you have and then start working on it
apart from the research uh topics that
you are sharing in the chat please feel
free to unmute yourself and you can also
ask in question if you have related to a
topic or a field how you can work on it
and for those who are from different
white lab Fields as many of you
mentioned you're from biochemistry field
or microbio and also we have uh
participants from pharmacyp for those
who are new to these different omic
studies all together you can go through
the introductory courses the first
course is Introduction to bioinformatics
which will give you an understanding of
what the field bioinformatics cells what
is the role of the data and
bioinformatics and also the role of
bioinformatics in healthcare and it's a
very short coursework it will give you a
good nice understanding and introduction
to the field bioinformatics and after
this course you can go through bytes and
molecules
now this course bytes and molecules will
help you understand or get introduced to
different omics fields that I just
mentioned about
so if you are new to the field
bioinformatics you you can take up these
two portions the first one will lay off
a good base or a background for the
field bioinformatics and the second one
will give you a good understanding about
different Army speeds it's definitely uh
not possible and also uh not important
that you take up all the Amish Fields
all together to get a specialization
into you can pick one specific Comics
field that you are interested to get an
expertise on and start with its um
training and then work on a research
project on it and then maybe pick up the
other field
so to understand what type of data
analysis you want to work with and what
type of resource specialization track
you want to work on you can go through
this course on bytes and molecules so
all of these different research
specialization tracks that I took you
through we have them introduced in the
bytes in the molecules course for gas
bill so if you are new to the feed
Precision medicine but you have heard a
lot about it and you want to understand
what are the different scopes of
research in between Precision medicine
then you can take up the lesson 11 and
course 2 by 10 molecules to understand
uh the scope and application of
precision medicine and so are the other
ways of
um
the other fields for research that they
are in the course bytes and molecules
all right so that is all that I wanted
to mention I just wanted to introduce
you to different omics data fields and
different resource specialization tracks
that you can really work on with and how
you can identify the area of research
and trust that you want to go through
take some time you have the link of the
research project topics with you you can
explore this project topics page and we
share our email address with you as well
if there is anything that you want to
discuss with us for any guidance you can
reach out to us and we'll be there to
assist you with your questions
and with that I would now like to pass
on the stage to Sri gauri to invite a
presenter for today Miss harshita
srivari odudu
thank you so much so uh before we uh
move ahead let me quickly share my
screen and show you some of the various
outcomes that we have as a part of
students completing their product
so as sonarika mentioned we do have
several projects that are published on
the portal but apart from that there are
several other possibilities and outcomes
that the students have showcased after
completing the research fellowship
program so to begin with majority of the
students are focused on publishing their
work for instance rupee virgin a
biomedical science graduate student she
worked on assessing the underlying Basin
for development of gray matter relations
in multiple sclerotic patients further
she went on to publish her work in
immunogenetics which is an Open Access
Journal that focuses on genetic research
areas of autoimmune disorders
and another interesting student
publication is that of a a genetic
engineering student he studied the
effect of malaria vaccine on the
transcriptional profiles of patients to
determine its efficacy and understand
the molecular mechanisms underline the
protection that the Watson offers he
also went on to publish his work in
genomics and informatics which is the
official Journal of the Korea genome
organization
presently we also have several other
students who are working on their
Publications like nivedita arundham who
is working on transforming study of
cancer treatment on patients and its
After Effects leading to relapse like
her we are looking forward to several
other Publications from our parents
whether we also have the opportunity to
participate in poster presentation
competitions as a part of the omics
research Symposium to an exciting cash
prizes
the student projects are not just
limited to graduates or doctorates for
instance Andre muradino a high school
student at Mexico presented his
Neuroscience project at the regenerborn
international science and engineering
pen for which he won the potamkin prize
and the fourth award in the biomedical
and Health Sciences category
and this program can also be integrated
as a part of the existing University
curriculum for instance find biotech
offered machine learning for biomedical
data post which was integrated into the
systems medicine graduate program at
Georgetown University and the lecturers
were prepared considering the interest
of the program director and the training
ended with students submitting their
research projects on the women's project
law importer and these project topics
range from intellectual diseases
metabolic disorders Neuroscience
psychiatric disorder oncology machine
learning all of these projects are upon
reporting and all of you can have a take
a look at it and these projects can also
be showcased for higher studies and
International University application
like some of our research fellowskin she
got accepted to the arrest Mendes imprc
program and she is presently majoring in
Marine Biology dhruv mehra he is a
Precision medicine bachelor program
student in Manchester University and
Anusha ta got accepted to the PHD
program in metagenomics at the
University of Sweden faculties and
researchers have also collaborated to
our programs to publish their research
work and our latest collaboration has
been with a team of researchers at
noguchi Memorial Institute for medical
research at University of Ghana to carry
out a computational based study to
understand variance associated with
sulfadoxin resistance and plasmodium
and it is also possible to pursue an
entrepreneurship and business Innovation
track like a team of industry
researchers from biologic support
from biotechnology company in Nigeria
and their aim was to improve the
fertility of women in Nigeria and
improve their chances of carrying their
babies to term by developing a kit test
and the entrepreneurship track is not
only pursued by industry researchers or
academic researchers they're also
pursued by students for instance a group
of undergraduate and postgraduate
students worked on developing an early
detection kit as a part of their aim to
identify and detect neurological
disorders with a specific focus on
Alzheimer's disease so all of these are
just very few examples that I just
wanted to Showcase among several other
outcomes that we have seen and with that
I would like to pass on the stage to
harshita to hear from her about how she
has carried out her research project on
rheumatoid affect
overdue
hello everyone I hope my voice is clear
and Audible
so I'll share my screen
yes
hello everyone my name is harshika and I
was a research value student and find
biotech my project was mentored by Dr
rakul sir
my topic of the project was a
comparative analysis of RNA expression
and M6 uh a methylation in pneumatite
arthritis
so before starting the projects uh what
these are the courses that I've been
through to finalize and come to the
to select a topic so first of all uh I
just worked casually understood about
the introduction to bioinformatics so
this course gave me a brief outline
about different sectors that are present
in bioinformatics
um where and all bioinformatics will be
used or is currently used everything was
given in this course then
uh then coming to the specifically data
in life sciences what is data and how it
is you know how they produce data from
sequencing different type of sequencing
and uh why it is important to store data
why it is important to analyze and study
those data not just single data
um multiple datas are taken so why it is
done and its advantages its applications
everything was given in this course
so uh after that I went to the next
course wherein uh designing and
bioinformatics project so in this
project a clear view was given uh how to
select a topic how to do a literature
review and what are the things you can
look into while selecting the project
and when you do other literature review
you'll know what is the reason work
which is done in a particular this is
for example
um I selected arthritis so what are the
what type of data they are taking what
type of analysis they are doing and
which a part of or which area of the
analysis is not
um discovered or understood more so
we'll know about all these things when
we do literature review
so uh after that uh doing the literature
review so I wanted to analyze the
methylation pattern and also the normal
RNA expression pattern so I'll just
quickly went through this epigenomic
course before starting with the
transcriptomes because
um you as we all know
um epigenomics
was
um study of mechanism that causes
changes in the gene expression but there
is no change in the DNA sequences
so this epigenomics plays a major role
in uh studying various diseases
then in the transcriptomic course
um starting from how we should select
the data how the data is pre-processed
so usually when a data comes from
sequencing
um you know in the lab when they do when
they send for sequencing adapters are
attached there are a few duplicates when
we sequence there may be few duplicates
so to remove that what are the
pre-processing steps are done about that
they studied then
how to map so we have a set of sequence
then we choose to map it with the
sequence which are already present that
is mapping with the genome or mapping
with the transcript of transcripts sorry
so these things are explained once we
get the data so after we select few
samples for example in my study I took
15 samples
so in that they checked whether
um all the sample are showing variable
variation only when it shows some amount
of variation there is a use of analyzing
it so one mean of testing that is
principal component analysis
uh so this was the brief of what is done
in transcriptomics uh that is analyzing
the gene expression so after there is a
one tool called or D set and Edge R so
this tool basically gives you the
differentially expressed Gene means
um in a this is some of the genes are up
regulator they are expressed high or
some of or down regulated they are not
expressed but they should be expressed
so this that to know this differentially
Express expression analysis is done
then at last just bio ml gives you a
detail about how to do statistical
analysis starting from the t-test
and um when in the machine learning uh
process which we I used in this project
was from the D by info server so what
happens in the each step and how to
interpret those data we may get the data
of very quickly within few days but it
is also important to interpret the data
you know so how to interpret it how to
know whether
this data is giving some amount of good
information and everything
so yeah this was all about the courses
then um uh before going to the results I
I would like to give some
interaction about pneumatic arthritis so
it is a chronic inflammatory joint
disease which causes
um bone damage and cartilage damage
which when left untreated ultimately
leads to disability
uh primarily the synovial joints are
affected because the
the cells attacked by pathogen and our
own cell our immune cells fails to
differentiate between this and they
attack our own cells so yeah there's a
type of autoimmune disease so usually
the emergence of RA or pneumatic
arthritis is apparent after the immune
Cell Activation and proliferation
including T and B cells monocytes
monocytes so these cells when they see
that there are high amount of
proliferation or when they are
circulated in high amount they confirm
that
um there is a re specifically in the
synovial membrane so uh for now there
are different drugs used for managing ra
which includes this is modifying
anti-numeratic drugs however a
significant amount of patients do not
respond to this drug
uh because the combination of re its
occurrences not only genetic it's also
environmental and mainly the epigenetic
factors
uh which causes the variation in drug
response
so for my study I took um
modification called m6a which is an
epigenetic modification
so I also mentioned earlier what is
epigenetics so it is and study of
heritable and reversible changes in gene
function which do not invoke any changes
in DNA sequences and the three important
epigenetic modifications that are widely
studied
this DNA methylation is done
modification and non-coding underneath
so in my study I took a m6a methylation
body which was altered in arthritis and
6A is nothing but the on the sixth
position of the methyl in the end group
The methyl group is added
so it is the most abandoned
post-transcript transcription RNA
modification this modification occurs
both in coding and non-coding RNA
so yeah that it involves methylation of
the sixth position of only the adenine
basis in the RNA molecule
the
aim and objectives for my project was to
study the differentially expressed Gene
and this regulator methylated peaks in
normal arthritis so I studied both of
the both of the data
um I mean there were five data which
were used for studying the
differentially expressed in and the
other five data with the control was
used to study the m6 and methylated
Peaks
um while doing this
um our aim was to find the common genes
that were enriched enrichment which was
differentially expressed in RNA seek and
meritc which is nothing but methylated
RNA or immunoprecipitation sequencing is
the method by which this data was
generated
and after finding the differentially
expressed genes in both of these groups
which Pathways were enriched were found
and
um then to understand the importance of
RNA methylation opposed transcriptional
modification and how it causes prog
losses in ra disease
so here is a brief Outlook now outline
of my project so I selected this
bio project under the code uh prj and
e795351 which is available in ncbi
then I explored the data to find
variations and if there were any
outliers using principal component
analysis then I use these tools
tribomatic PCR clean feature to headset
C tools which was run on T by info
server then after that I studied uh
differentially expressed Gene using a d
sector tool for the input and IP sample
so after a pre-processing all my data I
did separate study on input which is the
rnac data and IP year refers to the m6a
methylated data so now I got two groups
after studying it
um I could find some of the gene which
were
upregulated or in the case of
methylation they mentioned it as hyper
methylated so some of the genes were
present in both the groups like they
were common and also similarly down
regulator and hypometer
so
um as I could see that there was some
amount of Gene that back both common in
this added an conjoint analysis to find
to separate the
all of these common genes again into two
groups wherein upregulated and Hyper
methylated one group and other group was
down regulator and hypomethylated
um I would like to mention that hyper
methylation means when more amount of
methyl group is added or present in the
adenine base
and hypo methylated is when the
methylated groups or or methyl group is
removed from the adenine base
so for all of those genes which were
found to be common I did or Gene
ontology and get enriched pathway
analysis to find a significant Pathways
that were associated in causing ra
disease
so here is the graph of the conjunct
analysis I did and the top Group which
on the right side uh in orange color
refers to the gene only the top genes I
took so out of which
um after
um
yeah to do one and one I could find 185
genes that were in the in this group
which is hyper and up regulator and some
with the names mentioned here or the top
genes I've also written on the right
side and similarly on the downside you
can see uh 139 genes that by showing
hypo and down regulations and these were
the top genes
so um I took those jeans and I did a
gene ontology and get pathway analysis
uh so
what are the main Pathways these genes
which showed High enrichment here what
are these streets which Pathways they
are involved in so when studying that I
could find the top Pathways and I
differentiated them into this tablet
column as you can see here this is for
upregulator and this is termed regulator
and hypometer so upper regulator genes
showing uh enrichment involved in this
of these Pathways
um this is not I would not say this is
exact but yeah someone so they were
intracellular receptor signaling pathway
somatogenesis negative regulation of uh
or type of aptopic signaling pathway
then positive regulation of cytokine and
neurogenesis then responds to oxygen
radical positive regulation of
intracellular signal transduction and
leukocyte aptopic Pathways so all of
these Pathways genes involved in this
Pathways for map regulator and hyper
methylator
and genes involved in these were down
regulated or they were not functioning
basically that what it means so uh the
pathways where cellular responds to
leukemia inhibitory Factor actin
filament
polymerization positive regulation of
gtps activity or acetyl transferase
activity sensory perception of
mechanical stimulus recycling endocyte
membrane and epipheral binding
so of with this I could conclude about
the array this is that it's the most
common or terminal disease and it is
characterized by immune cell
infiltration fibuloplasts like synovial
cell
hyper proliferation and cartilage and
Bone destruction so today numerous
Studies have demonstrated that immune
cells are one of the key targets for
treating Rea but looking at the m6a
methylation
um which is uh which occurs as an
internal modification in the eukaryotic
mRNA on this type of modification is not
only involved like other starting stage
this m6a or methyl groups are added
removed and all the part all the process
involved in uh was starting from
splicing its stability export and also
degrade reading of RNA metabolism so it
shows that this
methylation specifically M6 a is
um changed in all of these stages of RNA
metabolism they play a significant role
in various biological processes such as
viral replication cell differentiation
by controlling gene expression so the
relation between m6a enzymes immune
cells and ra suggest that n6a
modification offers evidence per
pathogenesis of REM which will help in
the development of new therapies for REM
therapists which are specifically
targeting this m6a can give us more
are like more brief treatments because
as you know that the methylation pattern
or epigenetic regulation is reversible
as these methyl groups are added they
are also demethylated or the methodox
remote so as they are reversible they
they can be targeted for developing new
therapies and RNA sequencing show that
multiple microorganas contained m6a
modification therefore m6a modification
is important for the biogenesis and
stability of at least some microorganas
in my data also
uh so here on the right side I could
find one microatony which was showing
hyper methylation so there were many but
in the top I could find only one so this
also shows that we can um
you know study this micro rnas and it is
also important for um you know
biogenesis and stability of some of the
microorganas
extensive research on the methylation
mechanism of m6a has demonstrated that
regulation of RNA level related to m6a
is complex and diverse we believe that
further research on the mechanism of n6a
methylation of RA RNA and micro RNA in a
normal arthritis will have profound
implication for breathing or immune
disease specifically arthritis
so yeah
I'd like to thank
um find biotech and omix Logic for
providing me this opportunity to present
my work thank you
thank you so much harshika for
explaining your research project in such
an extensive manner and all the best for
your future endeavors
so
um now uh I would like to uh tell you
all about the research fellowship
program which harshika was a part and
what kind of Journey she followed or a
structure she followed so as to complete
her research project and then I'll
quickly explain about the resources
which one would have access to once he
or she enrolled in the program and then
what are the fee structure and the
scholarship available for everyone
so let me uh share my screen
I guess it's loading
okay uh so can anyone confirm if you can
see my screen like my screen screen is
visible
yes thank you thank you uh SRI Guardian
harshika
so uh this is the landing page of omics
logic
bioinformatics and a data science
research fellowship program I'm pasting
the link here in the chat box so that
everyone can go through once uh the
webinar the meeting is over at your own
pace and look through the page what all
resources then what kind of structure we
follow what are the possible outcomes a
one would have when they enroll in the
research fellowship program so this
bioinformatics and data science research
fellowship program is not only for those
who are like kind of in their
intermediate or an advanced level and
they have a good thorough knowledge of
bioinformatics or data science
So This research fellowship program as
you can see it's like it's been designed
for all the young researchers who are
even in their beginner level and they
don't have any kind of knowledge uh
related to bioinformatics or data
science or any other uh ohmic field or
any kind of specialization track
so um in this research fellowship
program we offer a combination of online
resources and Mentor guidance so as to
prepare you and help you complete a
bioinformatics project so once you
scroll down you can see that there are
three different steps which we follow so
as to complete the research fellowship
program and uh you can come up and get
make you ready with your research
project for the publication part as well
so in a very Layman language I'll
describe all the three stages which one
has to in like has to go through so the
very first stage is get ready through
training so in very simple words like we
will train you we will train you
according to your research interest uh
through our omix logic learn portal so
as the name is depicting there are
training there is it's a training and a
learning portal as SRI gauri has already
showed you what are the different kinds
of lessons or example research projects
or case studies through which you can
like which you can go through and gain
those conceptual as well as theoretical
knowledge which will help you in the
second stage that is uh doing some
exploratory analysis or you can say
literature review and then preparing a
full methodology which you need to
follow so as to come up with some
results and then do the interpretation
of those results so the very first stage
is to train you whether you are just
getting started with bioinformatics or
you already have a lot of experience
we will train accordingly so for example
if someone is uh like in a voice in
bioinformatics so then we have a
specific coursework that is Introduction
to bioinformatics that will provide you
a Insight of what are the different
terminologies related to bioinformatics
how bioinformatics can be used in health
care how bioinformatics can be used in
translational research Etc then if
someone says that I don't know in which
particular research domain or which
particular specialization track I need
to choose and so as to complete my
research project for that we have a
second coursework that is bytes and
molecules where we are transiting a
student transiting a participant from a
beginner level to an advanced level uh
where we are describing that participant
or a student about the technology as
well as the application
so there you will find some of the
courses or some of the lessons related
to introduction of different ohm XP like
space omics like genomics like
transcriptomics like metagenomics
epigenomics Etc and so these are the
Technologies which you learn a very
introductory part and when it comes to
application you will have lessons
related to Precision medicine then you
will have some other components of our
language also then Python language also
so this is how we will train you from a
beginner level and then transit to your
advanced level so that you can upscale
your knowledge related to your res
related to The Domain in which you have
shown interest
now here are the topics which we'll
cover in the training stage that is
first introduction to bioinformatics and
the basics of data in life sciences
second is omix data types like genomics
transcriptomic or metagenomics as I told
you third is data science in machine
learning for non-engineers and
biologists and the fourth is are in
Python Programming and in-depth
analytics for complex omics data
so for those who are interested to
interpret their results uh through our
Python programming language then there
would be in-depth analytics for uh like
in-depth review of the courses uh for
them those who don't want there is just
an introductory level of courses also
just to introduce you what RN python is
all about
now once your training is over we'll be
transiting you to the second stage that
is fine and impact impactful research
topic so here you need to learn how to
perform literature review and how you
need to plan out your research project
that is the methodology which you need
to follow so that you can come up with
the results and in and eventually do the
interpretation either statistical or the
biological
so uh there are a few points which you
need to keep in mind while you are in
your second stage and you are performing
uh the literature review you are
finalizing your data set on which you
need to work on you're preparing a
flowchart which you need to follow so
what are the few things first is make
your research question compelling to
those already in the field
set some specific parameters to answer
the research question conclusively and
third is find data set that fits your
objectives and explore them for batch
effects or bias and the fourth is get
feedback from our expert mentors on your
topic and Analysis proposal
so one thing I would like to make you
all clear over here is that this whole
research fellowship program is Mentor
oriented it's Mentor guided program
so at each and every step whenever
you'll get stuck you can take help of
our expert mentors and our expert
mentors are from either industry or from
Academia not only
um like Mentor if Mentor guidance you
will also have Online technical guidance
for example while going through with the
analysis phase if you found a finite
technical glitch in the T by info
platform so we have a particular team
assisting you for that also now once
your analysis is over you have results
the last part results you have the uh
interpretation Etc then the last part is
present your analysis for expert
feedback develop a complete project
ready for expert review and feedback and
once your analysis is done your
interpretation is done you have the
noble finding you need to jot it down
everything in a proper manuscript
scientific manuscript or a report so
whatever you have done throughout your
research fellowship program
so that you can gain expert review and
feedback
okay if you are thinking if you are
planning out for any research
publication or maybe presenting your
research project in any of the Symposium
or any of the international conferences
so there are some potential outcomes
once your research project is done is
complete a completed successfully and
some of the outcomes are listed over
here
so the first is expert feedback and
overall evaluation of project quality
Innovation and Analysis execution second
is poster presentation at the research
fellowship meeting or research Symposium
and by research Symposium I would like
to inform everyone and rather I would
like to invite all uh that we are
conducting we are organizing a two days
research Symposium in March on 30 and
31st I'll quickly show you the landing
page of research Symposium also in the
end
and third is path to collaborate with
expert mentors or faculty at partner
universities and fourth is path to a
full publication a research publication
in a good peer-reviewed journey
now uh there are four different tenures
in which one can enroll so or right now
we have like on my screen there are
three different tenures only which has
been displayed but there are four
definitely one is 45 days another is 60
then is 90 and then it's 180 days so
three months and six months option is
also available so the resources for all
the tenures are common that is
asynchronous courses Hands-On
assignments group sessions program
course access or mix logic portal access
t-bio info server access then online
Mentor assistant Online technical
assistance certification after
completion Etc so these are the common
resources which you would have access to
uh the difference is the outcome
obviously if someone would enroll for 45
and 60 days they cannot think of a
full-fledged research project which is
which can be publishable also so the
outcome of 45 and 60 days is a
literature review a kind of intermediate
level of analysis and a project report
for that intermediate level of analysis
and then for 60 days it's uh there is
one more addition that is a research
poster presentation like they can
present their poster in a research
Symposium then for 90 days and 60 days
there is obviously a research poster
project report literature review and a
research paper publication also
so these are the outcomes the tenures
Etc now when it comes to the payment I
would like to tell you I would like to
redirect you to a program page so that I
can show that we have different uh
payment options depending upon the
locations of our participants and here
I'm pasting the link of the program page
in the chat box
so
I'll firstly show the payment in USD for
all the participants who are there in
America or Canada Etc
countries out India
so uh
so for 45 days it's dollar 350 for Six
States dollar 450 and for 90 it's total
of 550 and uh someone if someone who is
from any other country for example from
Europe or from Brazil from India they
can simply click on the currency and
they can see the pricing in their own
country currency so for Indian a
community for 45 days it's 9 000 for 60
days it's INR 15 000 and for 90 days
it's they're not twenty thousand and uh
right now we I would like to inform you
that yes we are providing scholarship to
all those students uh like especially to
students and also to those participants
who are from low income countries so
there is a scholarship opportunity
available and those who are interested
they can either ping me on my email
address uh shigori can you please share
the details of
uh me the email address and the contact
number in the chat box so they can
either mail me or they can uh directly
connect me uh on WhatsApp so the number
which your body will share
um yeah so the number which is being uh
shared in the chat box it's active on
WhatsApp and you can directly ping me on
Whatsapp and I can we can discuss uh how
much scholarship one could have so uh
yes so this was all about the resources
the tenure the outcomes the payments Etc
and when you scroll down further you can
check out
our students projects also so on
different domains like infectious
disease research then space omics then
Precision oncology then for machine
learning and modeling then related to
some skin disease data driven drug
Discovery Etc and then eventually you
can find out our collaborators from all
around the world and the mentors of
research fellowship program and then
some related books about our students
research project their success stories
their achievements Etc so this was all
about the research fellowship program
which I would like to tell you and I'll
just quickly show you the
landing page of research Symposium also
give me a minute
yes
so I'll I'll again share my screen
uh just a moment okay now I guess
everyone can see my screen and shigori
could you please share uh the link of
the research Symposium uh main landing
page in the chat box for everyone to uh
they can go through it yes
so this is the research Symposium page
that we are going to conduct on March 30
and 31 it's a two-day event and soon
we'll share the session schedule also so
for those who just want to be a free
listener they can they can just simply
fill out the form which is uh here in
the end
so they can simply fill out the form and
we'll get the registration and we share
the zoom meeting link accordingly with
them
now uh when you'll scroll down here is
what we'll be focusing on like in the
research Symposium we'll be discussing
about how one can enable like advances
in enabling Technologies then what are
the different career opportunities and
bioinformatics or computational biology
we'll be showcasing you research
projects through our poster presentation
competition and uh we'll be having like
some exciting cash prizes also for that
and then how one can get involved in
finding Labs programs and mentors
basically uh like
getting get like
talking to each other talking to
like-minded people and uh getting your
things review getting your research
project reviewed to expert mentors
throughout the globe so this is the
research Symposium page again we have
categorize a research Symposium page
into three categories basis on the
student then faculty researcher and then
the poster presentation so uh
first of all it is free for the
listeners those who want a certificate
for a two-day event so they like it's a
very minimal amount of fee that we are
charging that's dollar five and if they
can if they'll click on this they'll be
redirected to the uh
check out like the payment checkout page
they can fill out their payment details
see so it's just dollar five for
students and for students only
so they can fill out their card details
and proceed with the payment check out
for faculty and researchers it's dollar
10 and for those who want to be a part
in a poster presentation competition so
there is a fee of dollar fifteen and
these are the excess which they'll have
once they'll pay for the poster
presentation or if they are a faculty or
researcher or a student in under a post
graduate
so this is how you can explore this page
and uh
yeah so this was all about the research
fellowship program the omics research
Symposium and we are uh like on daily
basis we are rolling out some mails and
also uh posting uh about the research
Symposium Etc on our social media
handles so please do visit the social
media handles on either Facebook Twitter
LinkedIn or Instagram and keep yourself
updated regarding the same and also we
have created and even you can join that
also
So yeah thank you
if anyone is having any question please
feel free to Ping in the chat box and
I'll be there to answer your questions
thank you everyone and uh shigori over
to you
thank you so much it will pause for a
couple of seconds and uh if no one has
any queries we'll be ending in today's
meeting
so I see one query in the chat box of
uh Darius I'm so sorry if the
pronunciation is wrong he's asking for
can you resend the link to the
introductory courses could you please
share your email address with us and
we'll be mailing you out
uh about the introductory courses
the links
I guess no one has it for the queries
everyone is just sharing their email IDs
if uh no one has any further query we'll
be ending today's meeting and once again
you can reach out to us at any time uh
through the email ID and the contact
number that we have provided and with
that thank you everyone for joining
today's webinar and I hope you have a
great day and we look forward to seeing
you at the research Fellowship group
thank you everyone
thank you everyone so we have noted your
email address we'll be mailing you thank
you